i think there's a strong argument to be
made that england was the most powerful
and successful imperial nation
of all time
but when you look back to the age of
exploration it becomes clear that
england was actually pretty late to the
imperial game as we know christopher
columbus backed by spain had arrived in
hispaniola in the new world in 1492.
he was the first european to start a
colony in the new world england by
contrast didn't actually have a
successful colonial venture in the new
world until 1607
with jamestown
now from this distance it doesn't look
that
far behind but this is more than a
hundred years later than spain's first
colonial ventures so what was england up
to why were they so late in the colonial
game that's what i'd like to take a
closer look at in this video and i'll
also talk a little bit more about what
conditions in england led that nation to
start new world colonies now i think the
biggest reason why england waited
another hundred years to have a new
world colony is that england had its own
problems and it had a number of problems
in this time period and we're talking
about the 1500s here
and the first of these was ongoing
conflict between catholics and
protestants in england now this is a
very long story i don't have time to do
justice to it here but suffice it to say
that the trouble started with henry viii
who we know from his many wives and many
beheadings and henry and viii broke away
from the catholic church in rome to
start his own church the church of
england also known as the anglican
church and this is a protestant religion
i'm going to put p here for protestant
now henry had two daughters elizabeth
who like him was a protestant
and mary
who was a catholic
and mary occupied the throne for a
number of years but elizabeth managed to
rest it away from her and once elizabeth
was on the throne
as elizabeth the first
england became a protestant nation so
it's hard to be involved in world
affairs when you've got kind of a crisis
of succession going on so one factor
here is religious conflict
another reason why england is not headed
over to the new world is that they have
colonial problems closer to home
in ireland
england is trying to and will succeed at
subduing ireland as one of its colonies
and they're undertaking a very bloody
and costly war and they think of this
catholic irish population almost as
barbarian savages who don't know what's
good for them and in the opinion of the
english what's good for them is english
rule and protestantism when of course
what the irish really want is self-rule
and to be left alone but they use very
brutal tactics against the irish and
we'll kind of see that again
when they're met with another hostile
colonial population in north america
another issue england is dealing with is
economic depression
uh the crown doesn't have a lot of money
and there's a great deal of crime
and poverty throughout the nation so
while the crown can't actually afford to
sponsor colonial exploits the way that
spain sponsored columbus they still
managed to get some riches out of the
new world by giving ship captains
license to plunder
spanish ships coming back with new world
riches and these were called privateers
the most famous of them here
is this man
sir francis drake
and really privateers are just pirates
with a fancy name
but the logic here was why bother trying
to set up a colony here in mexico or
south america
the west indies
and do all the work of setting up
housing and trying to tame laborers and
mining when instead you could just let
the spanish do all that and then put
that gold on a ship
and then use your awesome navy because
england is growing a very awesome navy
to
steal those riches
so england doesn't have a strong
incentive to do all the labor when they
can just steal it from the ships along
the way all right those are some of the
reasons why it took england so long to
start colonization in north america in
the next video i'll talk about the
factors that led england to finally join
the race for new world colonies